Now that you understand AVAudioRecorder,
it's time to get that
code into PitchPerfect.
In Xcode, open up the
RecordSoundsViewController.swift file.
Let's start by adding in the import
statement for AVFoundation right here,
underneath where it says import UIKit.
Inside the RecordSoundsViewController
class,
let's add our variable
to BD AVAudioRecorder.
I'm going to add it hear underneath
IBOutlet and call it AudioRecorder.
Scroll down to the recordAudio function.
In here we're going to add the lines for
creating the audio session, and
telling AVAudioRecorder
to start recording audio.
You can find all the code I've typed
here directly under this video.
At this point our code is
able to record the audio and
save it to the recorded voice .wav file.
What about when we
want to stop recording?
That is handled when the stop
recording button is pressed.
And you wired up that button to fire
up the function stopRecording in
the previous lesson.
Let's go there.
In the stopRecording function, let's add
these three lines to stop the recording.
We'll tell the audio recorder to stop,
and then we'll close out the session.
That's all it takes.
PitchPerfect is now able
to record your voice.
If you run it and press record,
you'll see the file name and
path in the debug console.